maintenir la paix dans les territoires
séparatistes ukrainien en d'autres
termes envoyé l'armée russe à donetsk
est lougansk c'est ce que permettent ces
deux décret signé par vladimir poutine
dans la nuit aucun calendrier militaire
n'est précisée dans ces documents qui
ont été publiés juste après une longue
intervention télévisée du président
russe il a accusé kiev d'être
responsable de la dégradation de la
situation et réitéré ses accusations
infondées de génocide et russes et
russophone d'ukraine par moments en
colère il a estimé que son voisin était
un pays artificiel est indissociable de
la russie se tenir prêt immo la ligne a
jugé nécessaire de prendre cette
décision de reconnaître immédiatement
l'indépendance de la république
populaire de donetsk et de la république
populaire de lougansk navrant donné les
problèmes dans la nuit dans une adresse
à la nation le président ukrainien lui a
répondu mme nasri semblait nous sommes
sur notre propre terre nous n'avons peur
de rien ni de personne jours nous ne
devons rien à personne et nous ne
donneront rien à personne george iny
qu'on évite damman volodymyr lnd qui a
également appelé ses partenaires
occidentaux un soutien clair et efficace
la décision unilatérale prise par
vladimir poutine suspend le processus de
paix dans ses territoires séparatistes
initiées par les accords de minsk en
2015 depuis l'annexion de la crimée en
2014 moscou n'a cessé de soutenir ces
deux régions autoproclamées où la guerre
continue